we start with this the massive fire that
burned in the southwest valley overnight
alex
yeah look at this video this is from the
fire just around midnight last night
started at an apartment complex that's
what that was
under construction that's near trop and
fort apache and those flames could be
seen
for miles we've seen a lot of great
video from a lot of viewers so thanks
for sending that in
and we welcome you here at five o'clock
good morning everybody i'm alex baggett
i'm john langler so we have team
coverage this morning
bianca holman takes a look at how close
the fire came to other homes and
businesses
yeah but we want to first start with
hector mcchia he is live from the scene
with the very latest good morning hector
hey there alex and john this fire was so
large at one point it brought as many as
a hundred firefighters from multiple
departments so let me show you what it
looks like right now you can see
crews have made significant progress
since about midnight crews still on the
scene
shooting water still on hot spots and
off to the left in the middle of your
screen you'll see
the building we're talking about these
were over 200 apartment units
that were under construction they're now
destroyed but the good news this morning
no reports of injuries but firefighters
still out here we've seen flare-ups out
in the distance inside the building
that you see has several floors it has
scaffolding around it the clark county
fire department tells us
this was the eli at ford apache project
it was halfway done but now considered a
total loss and we rushed out here as
soon as we got word of this breaking
news
by fort apache and tropicana at one
point though the flames
appeared to shoot hundreds of feet into
the air
we are told this is actually one of the
biggest fires for some of the crews out
here
and it's all hands on deck we have
firefighters from clark county
las vegas north las vegas and henderson
fire departments
and the winds made this incredibly
difficult for them to fight overnight
and i just for some perspective you know
this is directly behind the crossroads
plaza shopping center close to
businesses and homes
and back out here live at the center of
your screen this is another part of the
construction project
don't know exactly what was there but
you can see
the flames just flattened whatever
structure was there
still flare-ups and again right now the
fire department cannot go inside to
begin looking into what started this
fire in the first place
but this is the situation developing
here at the shopping center reporting
live hector mejia
back to you hector thank you very much
so when that fire started many of you
grabbed your cell phones and took video
like that
captured some amazing video bianca
holman is live with what people and
bystanders close to the fire saw
overnight bianca good morning
good morning john so we're actually on
the south side of this fire
again you can see crews right behind me
still working this fire
and we're just here right in front of a
few businesses a shopping center
and it was a very close call for those
who were just steps away from this
massive fire
now we received dozens of pictures and
video from folks at home who were
steps away from this there were pictures
where the flames were so high they could
be seen
from the 215 highway and the smoke was
being carried away
by those heavy winds overnight that we
all heard and now here are some
also some more photos from a different
angle firefighters at work
tearing through the fence to control the
blaze
and also pictures from the gas station
that shows you just how dangerous this
fire was to the surrounding area
and finally there's video from an
apartment complex there was a person who
was in there at their apartment and you
could see from their window a scary view
for those waking up to sirens overnight
and so again lots of viewer video and
pictures shared on social media
so for everyone at home you know again
we appreciate you all sending that
information in and sending those
pictures and video in
and also coming up in the next half hour
we're going to talk about the
evacuations
that were mandatory for folks who were
living just nearby because again there
are still people living in this area not
just businesses so we're going to talk
about those evacuations
coming up in the next half hour back to
you guys in the studio